je suis franco allemande d'une certaine
manière à produits d'appellation
d'origine contrôlée parce que je suis
vraiment né en allemagne de parents
allemands avec une éducation allemande
je suis arrivé en france à 24 ans et
j'ai épousé un français et donc les deux
pays les deux étapes tient vraiment à
coeur et je crois que sans nier nos
différences interculturelles si on
trouve la complémentarité on peut être
extrêmement bénéfique pour toute l'union
européenne
ça m'a beaucoup touché quand j'ai été
élu à la commission des affaires
européennes enfin quand j'ai été élu
président parce que c'était le jour des
obsèques
simone veil et j'ai participé à ces
obsèques et là j'aurais son petit
justement à une grande reconnaissance et
une grande responsabilité aussi par
rapport à la vie de simone veil et au
passé franco allemand c'était une
commission qui a un rôle de veille d'
analyse et prises de position sur des
questions européennes cette commission à
48 membres
ces 48 membres sont également
dans des commissions permanentes donc on
est la seule 48 parlementaires qui
siègent en fait dans deux commissions
c'est en quelque sorte un travail aussi
en double mais c'est nécessaire parce
que les questions européennes sont
transversales touche à beaucoup de
domaines politiques qui sont également
traitées par des commissions permanentes
les 27 états membres
ils ont tous une commission des affaires
européennes mais nous n'avons pas tous
les mêmes prérogatives
je suis toujours un peu jalouse de la
commission des affaires européennes
finlandaise elle s'appelle la base la
grande commission et elle mandate le
premier ministre ce qu'il a à défendre
au conseil
et vous voyez nous on est quand même un
petit peu loin de ça mais on a quand
même aussi une influence on adopte des
résolutions où on donne véritablement
aussi notre avis tout ça c'est un
dialogue qu'on a avec des institutions
européennes avec la commission donc est
particulièrement aussi avec nos
parlementaires européens nous défendons
les intérêts de la france
bien sûr est par contre je dire on a un
volet
d'action intérieur et extérieur à
l'intérieur nous informons aussi nos
collègues en forme de pédagogie aussi à
apporter dans les commissions
permanentes en disant attention quand le
champ de compétences de l'union
européenne est concerné nous devrons
nous devons nous être saisi et nous
prononcer oui un rôle très important
qu'on va avoir
c'est accompagné la présidence française
de l'union européenne qui démarre donc
en janvier 2022 et il ya un grand volet
interparlementaire réunion
interparlementaire qui va être un peu à
la manoeuvre pour accompagner ce qui est
mise en place par le gouvernement avec
ces trois mots relance puissance
appartenance et j'espère que tout le
monde doit s'impliquer aussi tout au
long de l'année pour justement préparer
cette
cette échéance là